LIMITED SCHEDULE OF CLASSES.
BRET, BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
THE SURGE OF FAME BASED IN
INCREDIBLE PAIN FROM THIS WEEK.
CHANGING GUN LAWS COULD BE A
MONUMENTAL TASK.
ONE REASON, MANY OF THE
DECISIONS ARE MADE ON THE STATE
LEVEL.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
EXPLAINS HOW THAT WORKS.
>> STATE STRENGTHENING THEIR GUN
LAWS WITHOUT SPRING COURT
INTERFERENCE CONTINUED TODAY.
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS LEARNED
THEY COULD PROCEED WITH THEIR
PROPOSED TEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
TO BUY GUNS, THE SECOND LONGEST
WAIT IN THE COUNTRY.
>> FEDERAL LAWS PROVIDE A
CERTAIN BASELINE EVERY STATE
HAVE TO RESPECT.
BUT ABOVE THAT, STATES ARE FREE
TO VARY HOW THEY REGULATE GUNS.
WE HAVE WIDE DIVERSITY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AN OVERWHELMING 77% OF ADULTS
POLLED BY "THE WASHINGTON POST"
"WASHINGTON POST" AND ABC NEWS
DON'T THINK CONGRESS IS DOING
ENOUGH TO PREVENT MASS
SHOOTINGS.
A MAJORITY 62 PERCENT DON'T
THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING
ENOUGH.
WHEN STATES ACT FASTER THAN THE
FEDS, THE RESULT ARE SOMETIMES
MIXED.
>> CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE A LAW
THAT BANS THE POSITION OF
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES BUT
ACCORDING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT, NO
ONE HAS TURNED IN ONE OF THESE
MAGAZINES.
>> ON A STORE CARD -- SCORECARD,
FLORIDA IT'S A F.
THE GROUP CONCLUDES CONSISTENTLY
WE SEE A POWERFUL CORRELATION.
STATES WITH STRONGER LAWS HAVE
FEWER GUN DEATHS PER CAPITA
WEALTH STATES WITH WEAKER LAWS
HAVE MORE GUN DEATHS.
OVER HALF A DOZEN STATES GET A'S
INCLUDING MARYLAND WHERE THERE
IS A UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECK
FOR ALL HANDGUNS AND ASSAULT GUN
PURCHASES.
MARYLAND'S GUN LAWS DIDN'T STOP
THIS CLARKSBURG HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT FROM BUILDING AN ARSENAL
WITH AN AR-15, AND MULTIPLE
GRENADES.
POLICE SAY HE HAD A LIST OF
GRIEVANCES.
>> IF A DETERMINED CRIMINAL
WANTS TO DO HARM, THEY DO HARM.
IF YOU HAVE A STATE BANNING A
RIFLE JUST BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THE REAR HAND HOLDS THE RIFLE,
THAT'S JUST RIDICULOUS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OPEN TO
BEEFING UP THE NATIONAL
BACKGROUND CHECK BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS JUST AS
ALARMED BY THE FBI'S FAILURES.